there's a new black panther with a new
look in Marvel Studios black panther
wakanda forever so to get the scoop on
the suit I'm talking with Marvel Studios
head of visual development Ryan Miner
dang hi Ryan hello
well let's jump in shury's New Black
Panther suit is an incredible take on an
already iconic suit so as you started
work on this film how did you approach
this new design one of the great things
about shuri in the first Black Panther
movie was that she had like pretty
amazing iconic looks across the board
some that Ruth Carter designed some that
the visual development team designed we
were trying to look at pretty early on
with how to translate some of those
things into the Black Panther suit and I
think with shuri we were trying to find
almost a slightly more Fierce look I
think we were trying to evolve her into
a character where she was stepping into
the mantle in a way that was
tremendously her own and and that
involves becoming a sort of more Fierce
version of black panther
it's such an awesome design what were
some of the key visual elements you and
the team were looking to incorporate in
terms of the overall aesthetic of the
suit it's kind of the same as the other
Panther suits where we're trying to make
it as Skin Tight to her body as possible
so it feels flexible it feels like she
can be acrobatic she can be strong and
powerful and doesn't have to have any
sort of restrictions on her at all you
know one of the things that ran cooler
asked for is sort of maybe even Weaponry
or you know starting with her Panther
gauntlets becoming even larger or
because she is a you know obviously a
technology expert that the tech became
added on and those things got bulkier
and and almost made the suit look more
powerful through having technology as
part of a visual language but as we got
into it we did realize we had so many
amazing visual reference points from
shuri in the previous movie that we were
kind of hearkening back to those a lot I
think the biggest sort of change in the
suit in the previous designs is
fundamentally sort of the boldness of
the design language as well as the
panther gauntlets and a few pieces of
gold around her shoulders that are a
little bit stronger and meant to give
her a little bit more of a shoulder
silhouette than she would have had
without them well you packed so many
amazing details into this suit how many
iterations of Shari's suit did the team
create before settling on the final
design we probably had 50 or 60
different designs I think there was a
lot of really amazing things to play
with and having the comics is a base but
also having those amazing appearances in
the first movie as a place to start was
basically where we began
I think we ended up landing on one that
had that sort of fierce look with things
that represented Panther teeth both on
the top and bottom number jaw and
specifically pulling from her Warrior
Falls look where she had a a number of
white dots painted on her on her face we
were trying to turn those into sort of
graphic elements that are done in silver
and then finding all those things
integrated it into one cohesive look was
one of the more fun parts of the process
and again bringing that gold and silver
in to sort of say that she's now at a
place where she's stepping into the
mantle taking on all of the burden of of
where her country is at and trying to
save the day now of course shuri isn't
the first person we've seen take on the
mantle of the Black Panther are there
any parts of this design that referenced
previous black panther suits one of the
fun things about Marvel Studios and
Marvel Comics is that there are
characters that have these sort of
mantles that can get past from one
character to another that symbol of that
mantle becomes different and changed in
some way when the new character takes it
over the suits that we start with end up
meeting something and then how they
translate into the next film and the
next film all seem to like become useful
in the storytelling going forward and
when we were working on the Black
Panther suit for civil war that ended up
being sort of termed sort of t'challa's
suit I think in the Black Panther movie
where t'challa explains to shuri that
was what he had developed and sure he
creates that suit in Black Panther right
and killmonger ends up taking that gold
suit and sort of making it his own at
the end of that film essentially the
suit that shuri ends up with is kind of
a combination between t'challa suit and
killmonger suit a mix of the silver and
the gold that's the panther she needed
to become in order to be able to fight
Neymar at the end there are some subtle
nods to each one of those suits in the
final design but it really is as simple
as the color schemes being the silver
and the gold being the two things there
is a bit of through line for it her
representing her Fallen brother as well
as probably begrudgingly representing
things she needed to learn from
killmonger
so Ryan what did it mean to you to be
able to continue the legacy of the Black
Panther in the MCU through a new
character and this new design
the fact that we were able to to work on
shuri in Black Panther and to see her
sort of transition into a full-on black
panther of her own in Black Panther will
kind of forever it was an amazing
experience like the the idea of watching
that character take on a mantle do
things that she didn't think she could
do try to live up to her brother's
memory for me it's to have been part of
this journey of watching this character
become beloved by the audience and the
fans and trying to figure out how sure
he can feel like she's she's taking that
mantle and carrying it Forward was an
incredible experience
I am the Black Panther and I'm here for
Retribution well you and the whole team
really did an amazing job Ryan thank you
so much for talking with us thank you
it's great to be here thank you so much
and of course everyone go experience
Marvel Studios black panther wakanda
forever in theaters now